all right so I was sitting in my room
reading Fullmetal Alchemist because
that's what I do know apparently
wondering how I was going to start this
video and then boom literally a couple
of chapters past where I stopped last
video began the single best action or
plot sequence in the entire story up
until now it was freaking nuts like as I
said I'm a big dragon ball fan and I'm
reading this for the very first time but
there's a fight scene in this that's
impressed me more than any fight I've
seen in a long long time I have been
enraptured by the dialogue and the
twists and turns this thing has
presented me so let's not waste any time
and get into it because it's so damn
amazing this is my continuation of Full
Metal Alchemist
[Music]
to your mind
deception
espionage thrilling action like way too
much fire more fire that I'm comfortable
with personally and I'm not kidding when
I say that this manga just went from
great to incredible in the span of three
chapters and I cannot express just how
much I lost my mind while reading this
section so let's try to figure out how
they achieve this and Boya works so damn
well and to kick it off I am of course
going to be talking about the framing of
Lieutenant Maria Ross and the incident
at lab number three
to kick off this Trek through Peak
fiction Valley Lieutenant Maria Ross
everyone's favorite subordinate of
Colonel Mustang with a pistol gets
framed for the murder of Hughes now at
no point did I think that she was
actually guilty or to blame the story is
written such that you're meant to
sympathize with her which makes what
happens later oh so much more spicy
arakawa your one sadistic woman that has
a weird obsession with cows but that's
okay because you write incredible
stories but honestly a lot of that
deception here in this section is quite
thinly veiled however with that said it
did cause me to become all the more
anxious so that's a good thing with Ross
being wrongfully framed Edward and Al
finding out about this last minute and
Barry looking to Springer from the
prison this was clearly all built into
something significant and boy oh boy was
it ever
Donna
held out upon first discovering what was
left of the supposed Lieutenant Maria
Ross I was like okay story that was
pretty cool but little did I know that
the real stuff was just around the
corner naturally again I didn't think
that Mustang had this in him he had been
so dedicated to figuring out who
unalived Hughes that there'd be no way
that he'd be willing to without
hesitation overreact to an escaping
convict like this no chance particularly
when it comes to Ross especially given
what we know about her situation which
you might see as a negative in the story
should I have thought this was genuine I
don't really know but I honestly don't
think it matters because once again this
all just made me lean in that much more
as a reader something big was going down
and we weren't being told about it now
that said when the dental records came
up as a match I did have a brief moment
of pause as I can guess myself but you
know what I said no way no way Mustang
did that they had to figure out
somewhere around that and the fun out of
this after is handled remarkably well
from the action to the prior chapter to
this one the framing of events and tone
of the material is far much more subdued
and sad as Ed and Al go to visit
hughes's family to explain themselves
and to well apologize there's an
interesting lack of text or dialogue
instead allowing us to just exist in
these moments with these characters it's
some of my favorite panel work by
arakawa in all honesty and I think
that's saying something given what she's
done so far much the same way Ghibli
knows how to use silence in their
Productions to evoke certain feelings
from their audiences arakawa in this
chapter knew how to strip back her
stories such that the dialogue doesn't
get in the way of these compositions
she's constructed it's fantastic and it
only gets better from here
hmm
[Music]
this is where things really start to get
crazy and all the pieces we've seen not
quite make sense start to make more
sense and come together okay not exactly
there's still some confusion when
Armstrong randomly attacks Edward's arm
out of nowhere and then drags him back
to his hometown for quote repairs wink
wink and then you get Mustang chatting
on the phone to his girlfriend wink wink
and from this point on when the attack
on Barry the chopper using his old body
occurs in the apartment that they were
hiding out in I honestly don't think I
was prepared for what ultimately
happened afterwards as I mentioned in my
last video this seems to be a story that
has its focus squarely on the characters
and their respective stories and as a
result the story itself has been
spectacular but there hasn't been as
much emphasis on fighting as I would
have come to expect from certain Shonen
stories even with the more emotional and
subversive ones like Hunter Hunter that
series first Arc was entirely built
around showing install combating
competition whereas Full Metal Alchemist
has been extremely restrained and
measured in its approach I think
regarding fighting well that is up until
now because from this initial fight
spawns the single best and most exciting
sequences of fights I've seen in years
as a reviewer and I mean that so again
just for context my mindset going into
this was that I expected something was
up with Mustang and that Ross had to be
somewhere she couldn't be dead but I had
no idea how to Barry the chopper and his
crew hiding out in the apartment fitted
into this equation and just as I'm
thinking that landfan senses 20 Souls
encroaching on their location now that's
a super handy dandy ability and as soon
as Mustang rallies his forces for
support van fan just pieces out and
rushes towards those 20 Souls but first
of all can we just appreciate Mustang's
subversion here all those secret
conversations were all set up for this
ambush of an ambush to leverage this
occasion to bring him closer to the
answers that he's looking for the truth
within the truth if you will or whatever
that Marco guy said havoc and Hawkeye
pretty much go all guns blazing trying
to make a difference and that's when
something unaccounted for goes wrong
oh my God
time to deal with this now and uh uh so
bullets don't seem to work not great
given that you're the bullet girl okay
uh think about things and it's around
here I remembered what landpan said
earlier right before she dashed away she
sensed 20 Souls but then found Envy they
have all these lives trapped inside of
them or at least that's my impression
right now that's my theory maybe greed
never cared about dying because he had
so many Souls inside of him already he
had an overabundance of them you could
say I mean that tracks with the greed
moniker right and gluttony I can imagine
the same is true for him given how many
times he's been shot and laughed it off
like it was nothing but hey this girl
seems to be doing a number on Envy
successfully when upping Envy time and
again but not before shooting a flare to
alert Mustang to their location
hopefully he can get there in time to
save Hawkeye from gluttony
and this is just the beginning guys can
we talk about this not even being the
good yeah okay I have to chill please
you're a professional get it together
this is amazing okay everyone follows
the body of Barry the chopper back to
laboratory 3 as it Retreats back to base
and this is where stuff goes down my God
does it go down so the first thing that
blew my eyebrows off was the girlfriend
Havoc has been talking about
light-heartedly over the course of these
last few chapters
lost and she's ready to throw hands or
nails or whatever the Hell she's doing
but whatever it is it's scary and also
kind of hot but really scary primarily
and guys this section is like revelation
after Revelation I know I sound like I'm
freaking out but that's really the
energy of these chapters for a story
that's been holding its cards super
close to his chest since the beginning
only filtering the info out slowly
across many chapters seeing this flood
of information was insane like lost
demonstrating that her core is the
Philosopher's Stone and it's how they
were created like I don't even know what
that means Mustang and Havoc versus lust
I guess she's being present the entire
series but now she's taking Center Stage
it's time to face lust this is top tier
shown in Shenanigans If Ever I did see
it in the best of ways my God the beauty
of this sequence is chef's kiss I just
have to gush for a few seconds all right
because I found it that exciting and one
of the reasons it's great is primarily
due to the power system of the world in
question you can look at any great
Shonen story at nine times out of ten
their best fights are the ones that can
exist only within their established
World well once you remove character at
least Naruto Dragon Ball one piece they
all have amazing fights and most of
these great fights depend on the various
systems that they have in place whether
they are simple or complicated to give
the altercation its own sense of
Dramatics and Flair and Full Metal
Alchemist in this one is no different
it's been established that Mustang while
powerful seems to need a few things in
place in order to be effective or so we
were led to believe at this point he
circumvents transmutation circles thanks
to the gloves that he wears and
naturally if the area has too much rain
the fire that he users won't work these
are his limitations that any Dragon Ball
fan will tell you that once you add
limitations to a technique the tension
Rises and good old Ron the Roy Mustang
is no different here lost is in the
position of power and overwhelming each
of them and it's from here she makes a
calculated decision she floods the room
in water and Retreats further into the
building as readers and viewers we can
cast our minds back to earlier in the
story where the rain prevented Mustang
from using his abilities in the first
place and thus we assume this case is
identical to that one but we and she are
wrong and this is where arakawa writes a
simple solution that makes total sense
in her story Mustang uses Alchemy to
remove the flammable gas from the liquid
beneath him that is genius and not only
that turns the room she's hiding within
into a bomb
look that was awesome and Mustang says
things like oh yeah she's totally cooked
I can feel the fat in the air landing on
my lips I mean I gotta be real I didn't
need to hear that but it's a neat little
detail but you know what else is a neat
little detail
no
that not good for the heroes but it was
pretty cool and when she said I don't
like being broken up with I just know
arikawa was having all sorts of fun when
she was writing this one but the most
hardcore part is when Mustang with his
bare hands rips the Philosopher's Stone
out of her chest in an effort to stop
her and heal Havoc but she just begins
to regenerate around the stone itself
and his hand oh my God that looks so
creepy in the manga and it made me
wonder does this mean that they are the
stone that every stone that was created
is just another one of the homunculi
also I just noticed that if Lost Stone
is there in her chest and that's her
tattoo and that means that the Tattoo's
placement is directly correlated to the
position of the stone itself within the
host which means Bradleys is in his eye
and gluttony's is in his tongue whatever
the case it's a crazy set of
circumstances and it's so fun to watch
and speculate on and while things go
from bad to worse in this fight against
lust mister I'm the secret evil king of
the world Bradley shows up alone to
intervene at this point I was curled up
into a ball feverishly flipping from
page to page I needed to know how this
fight was going to end and with the
spooky disembodied voice of Pride the
only other homunculi on accounted for
for us calling both envy and gluttony
back to base it's safe to say that with
Havoc unconscious and Mustang on the
verge of death now mortally wounded
things aren't looking good guys
sorry enjoy
so lost walks away from Mustang leaving
him to bleed out instead choosing to
confront Alphonse Elric and while this
could be considered the downbeat of the
segment there's a lot of narrative
resonance to it I think a big motivating
factor for Al moving forward is to
ensure that no one has to pay for his
mistakes or lack of ability again and
when you think about it he's every bit
as capable as his older brother he just
has the wrong mindset about it in fact
every chance Edward gets he points out
just how much better his little brother
is than him whether it be fighting or
Alchemy or whatever Fullmetal Alchemist
as a title could very easily be talking
about Al and not Edward Elric in every
way that matters Al can be viewed as the
main character if you want to and in
this scene he shows a level of grit into
nasty that really made me respect him
all the more as a character
oh my God okay when this happened I'm
not kidding when I say I literally
shouted holy [__] and jumped off my
chair this this dude Ronnie boy Mustang
cauterized his own wound etched a
transmutation circle onto his own Fist
and used havoc's lighter as an ignition
point he's an app absolute animal and to
boot he actually kills lost can we talk
about him actually being the first
person to kill one of the homunculi I
mean okay I thought I thought this was
impossible this is the most amazing
fight scene and I just have chills
talking about it
Full Metal Alchemist
Switching gears now we have Edward's
side of the story to talk about and
analyze if you remember he was dragged
away before all this epic stuff went
down and while he does get dragged off
to the middle of the desert to see and
not dead Maria Ross oh hey look yeah
she's pretty alive and some ruins I
gotta say the best part of this section
reveals even more than what Alan
mustanga up to with Miss lost combust
for Anna's way to visit his mom's grave
in his hometown he runs into a familiar
face
oh
oh yep that's right it's pipeman or at
least he looks like the leader of the
monkey light I guess I mean he's got the
same beard and stuff but with that said
and jokes aside I actually loved this
sequence in the manga there's this super
interesting conversation between
hohenheim and Edward that takes place
right before his mother's and his wife's
grave hornheim draws attention to his
burned down home asking Ed why did he do
that and Edward gives his typical answer
so that he can't look back that it's a
symbol of his resolve his conviction in
his overall goal we are all too aware of
and to that his father disagrees saying
that it looks as though to him that Ed's
hiding his mistake so that he doesn't
have to confront them I personally don't
know how to feel about this Ed proves
this thinking was wrong almost right
away later in the story but then again I
don't know if he'd have dug up that body
in the backyard had he not felt his
father could have been onto something
here but ignoring that for just a second
I do think it's interesting that he
hohenheim levels that criticism at
Edward his son and my working Theory
right now is that it could very well be
hohenheim projecting think about it at
this moment in time we have no clue as
to why he's been gone for all these
years and then we see a scene like this
[Music]
earlier in the story hornheim reveals
that Ed is a lot like him and to that I
think what he means is that he's similar
physically yes but also similar in his
ability to get things done his
conviction and from that moment he moves
to take the only photo that exists of
Trisha his wife himself and his two kids
that exists right before leaving however
not before saying that something
terrible is coming and that pinako
should leave this country okay so
obviously I'm excited for the
implications of that last line but I'd
also like to further analyze what just
happened here because the aftermath is
sort of incredible to confront what his
dad just said Edward like I said digs up
the supposed body of his mother and
discovers that not the bones nor the
hair match his mother in the slightest
and through this discovery it's revealed
to Edward that he may be closer to
helping his brother regain his body that
he might think and the connect section
made here is memory
[Music]
the analysis and questions add posits to
the group upon his return are unreal
proving that Al is the real Al because
he has memories that he Edward couldn't
possibly know about and says that Al's
new memories the ones made after the
incident must be being stored in his
body somewhere that there's a connection
between the body and soul and that
connection is the spirit Al needs a
physical body to house his thoughts and
memories and so that's his theory that
it must exist somewhere and I think it's
an awesome Theory because it correlates
perfectly with what Barry the Chopper's
body confirmed for us early in the story
what was once so Random now acts as a
clever piece of foreshadowing of this
very thread that I never anticipated
I'll paid the toll to pass through the
portal of truth whatever that means and
so it begs the question what's the truth
that lies within the truth they're using
the word truth as like a noun in this
instance like it's referring to a
particular thing like a person or
something or an entity now I've known
Earth the idea what's going 9 but I do
have another theory so buckle up I'm
calling it here that hohenheim is the
leader of the homunculite but even
further beyond that there's a moment he
shares with Pinnacle where he alludes to
not appearing to age this is curious and
got me thinking perhaps he doesn't seem
to age for the same reasons the lifespan
of all the homunculi and villains seem
to be extended and maybe he has the same
goal Ed had to save his wife's life like
I mentioned before he seems to see a lot
of himself in Edward and if there's one
thing that's for certain about Edward is
that he's got some impossibly strong
convictions convictions that have led
him to do some horrible things both to
others inadvertently and to himself
carelessly and perhaps hohenheim is of a
similar mindset and capability perhaps
his wife Trisha was sick and told him
that she would hang on until he found a
way to extend someone's life beyond
natural means this would then make sense
of what Trisha said to Panico before she
died and it would explain why hohenheim
is so nonchalant about the time he
missed with his kids and his wife ten
years is an incredibly long period of
time to go without seeking or making
contact with them whatsoever and given
that he took the only photograph of them
together it implied at least to me some
sort of emotional connection or fondness
at the very least and so in my mind
taking the photo and choosing not to see
them for 10 years that doesn't really
seem to correlate or work together in my
mind unless time doesn't matter to him
because once he finds the answer to
immortality to his wife's death time it
won't matter it's infinite and if this
is true and is his goal then that
positions Edward as the perfect polar
thematic opposite to his father stopping
the ideology he once so feverishly
sought to bring into this world in the
past but through his experiences learn
the truth within the truth in the
process coming to appreciate that life
is so special and as as it is because it
ends eventually and that we should enjoy
what we have while we have it to prove
this Ed will have to stop his own father
from trying to resurrect his own mother
and to solve for immortality but that's
just a theory
and all right so we have a better idea
of what's going on now Ed and Al are
back together thankfully they're on the
same page brilliant they're determined
to shoulder all of this without getting
anyone else hurt and what's more they
have a plan
[Music]
this is a great plan it might have a
million different ways it can fail might
not get them what they want and might
also unalive them both but it's a great
plan nevertheless using themselves as
bait to lure in the homunculi to rescue
their supposedly valuable selves this is
a very clever and ballsy move by Edward
and I honestly love it it's so exciting
to watch too particularly when gluttony
and oh I forgot to mention yeah Glutton
Envy got Marco before Breda and Mustang
did to help havoc and he can't walk it's
sad whatever but as I was saying this is
a great plan simply because this time we
have a backup and I'm not talking about
Mustang
thank you
I've thought for a long time that line
fan and the folks from Beijing have had
a fascinating ability to sense what
makes the homunculi part of what they
are what gives them away that they are a
cluster of souls engulfed inside one
entity It's a Spooky fact but for it to
be true it's kind of a remarkably handy
trait for them to possess and this
ability they have it works they get
their hands on who they're after but as
it happens I was wrong not every
homunculi is built the same wrath
apparently he's built different he
passes as human not just to the broader
military not just to Edward and Al but
to landfan and Lin also which is crazy
because it leads to this he slices land
pan no and okay okay this is a weird one
not because Lan fan gets slashed
although that is certainly less than
optimal for her but you know that's not
what I'm talking about here you see in
the anime things progress as normal from
this scene henceforth the encounter
continues and we switch perspectives to
another altercation however in the manga
we get something entirely different we
get a short but Illuminating scene with
hoenheim On A Train That's taken over by
Bandits and in this scene he gets shot
like a dozen times to no effect he even
goes as far afterwards to refer to
himself as a monster now I'm not a
doctor but I don't think normal human
beings are able to do that and so it
further strengthens my case that he's
either modified or not at all human
anymore either way I think it's a really
strange choice for Brotherhood the anime
to not adapt that because on his face
it's a rather revealing and seemingly
important scene but oh well let's go
back to the slicy slice this this is a
surprisingly dramatic and strategic
fight and I didn't expect that at all
Lang fine is down and her only defense
now resides in Ling the person she's
been tasked to protect a character that
up until now has acted like a
freeloading spoiled Prince he's
demonstrated some righteousness but
we've seen very little of them in
serious action predominantly leaning on
a more comedic angle for a character
until now immediately he dashes to the
aid of his subordinate picking her up
and confronting wrath head on otherwise
known as king Bradley aka the scariest
character in this story I think it's
that aspect and our limited expectations
of Ling that creates this wonder when
Ling actually finds success he employs
strategy by consistently moving into his
blind spot created by the eye patch and
demonstrates a terrific level of combat
ability and even when cornered he's
always thinking about his next move it's
remarkable and he even finds time to
call out Bradley for being a fake King
adding a thematic element to it that a
king is for the people not the other way
around and with that throws a flash
grenade to Blind both gluttony and wrath
but one problem
foreign
that is freaking cool man I love that
this story doesn't just have fights for
the sake of fighting and Within These
confrontations has actual strategy Ling
is wildly and very game here achieving
all of this with his limited movement
while other stories would rely on
signature techniques time and time again
the combat in this story feels once
again very grounded and it's totally in
keeping with the tone of the story at
hand here a world filled with so much
magic and wonder but torn apart by The
Bitter reality of it all Ling doesn't
use magic or secret powers to overcome
wrath but instead takes advantage of all
the same traits that are apparent to us
at home other stories that rely on names
techniques certainly have their place
but there's just something so
satisfyingly unique and appropriate
about this story's approach it gives it
a really fresh identity I think and on
the flip side there's another fight
that's taking place that we return to
and unsurprisingly this one to add
variety focuses less on the combat
aspect and more on the words being
exchanged here this by Design isn't so
much a fight but more so Edward buying
as much time as he can however when Scar
confronted Eden Al with the ethical
Quagmire that was the state they let
Nina following show Tucker's hard Affair
it really elevated the reality of this
story once again Nina wasn't a throwaway
character that existed in an early
chapter were allowed to forget about
like Ed and Al wanted she wasn't some
NPC she deserved moral consideration and
Edward just left her because he had no
answers for her situation lonely cold
and scared they left her to just exist
in pain and Scar sought to that whether
you agree or disagree with his Approach
at least he did something that really
hit home for me this would be like if
one of the goons from the Red Ribbon
Army that Goku killed was brought back
to our attention by one of their family
it just retroactively changes the tone
of the entire story in a brilliant way I
think Ed does snap back at scar
concerning winry's parents and how he
took them out but unfortunately it was
at the wrong time
[Music]
this is honestly a terrific moment that
complements the reality I touched on
earlier something I've come to learn
over the years as a Reviewer is that
every series emphasizes different
aspects of their story to transport us
from point A to point B in Dragon Ball
and one piece it's perseverance and
tenacity the story leans on in Hunter
Hunter it's trauma in Attack on Titan
it's this Lust For Revenge but in Full
Metal Alchemist it's Humanity it's flaw
it's the unsightly elements of the real
world that make us feel uncomfortable
when looking at them it's The Healing
Hands of a genuinely caring and kind
person in Winery holding a deadly weapon
with the intention of ending another's
life this story truly and wonderfully
leverages the horrors of reality and
melds them with the fantasy elements
sprinkled throughout it's hope versus
despair but I am forever grateful that
Edward reminds her of who she is to him
it's such a beautiful moment nestled in
the horror of the occasion and I just
don't think anything could be more in
keeping with the tone arakawa is trying
to go for with this series it's an
outstanding scene and what's more is the
other fight scene crosses over into this
one
the following material is and I kid you
not literally hype moment after hype
moment after sad moment after
traumatizing moment after more hype
moments I was so excited reading this
week's material that she's meant
seriously The Story Goes Nuts so Ling
exploding from the super below throws a
flash grenade at gluttony this time
demolishing his upper body and what's
more is he ties what's left of his body
up in metal cables meaning gluttony's
regeneration ability is now working
against him I I think I love Ling
this is future Mark here and um about
lovingly I'm sorry pass Mark but you're
in free world of hurt later but yeah
anyway back to pass mark and as it
happened Lan fan didn't offer self which
is great for her and instead cut off her
own arm and turn it to a dog which is
not great for her but is a win for the
dog creating a fake blood trail for
wrath to follow I love strategy like
that it's so fun and by fun I mean you
know not in the body horror sort of way
come on
so look I've not spoken about this
little girl looking for Edward at all
that came from Jing uh and look I
honestly don't have any feelings one way
or the other about her of all the
characters in the story of which the
vast majority are great she's not really
vibed with me since she got here I mean
I know she's cute I know she has some
weird powers but I gotta see some more
from her so far she's kinda mid with
that said Lincoln landfan's side of the
fight has been exceptionally strong and
thankfully there's more where that comes
from later but not right now because the
fight's over and Winery is going back to
Ross Valley bye Winery pride and wrath
have a convo I still have absolutely no
earthly idea who pride is I mean he's
gotta be someone in the military right
or at least the government or someone in
power I just know this is going to be
another one of those reveals that will
completely take me off guarded I'm
anxiously waiting for it to happen
happen already alright so let's break it
down for just a second envy and Marco
have a conversation that reveals their
ultimate goal and when that goal was
revealed to me I was like
which is Irish for the following their
War has been in the name of Blazing a
trail that carves out an enormous
transmutation circle around massive
population centers in the land they plan
on sacrificing everyone in the circle to
create the ultimate Philosopher's Stone
when capable of God knows what and that
is such a comic book level threat it's
so massive that I can't even really get
like that's such a it's cool but it's
weird it's it's weird and like a
horrific kind of way but it's very good
I like it furthermore there's also this
air of the Youth of this generation
writing the sins of the past gluttony's
Rampage is terrifying and the design he
boasts is terrific here Mustang escapes
by the skin of his teeth leading Ed Al
and Lynn behind to fight
in
so Envy shows up looking like a sort of
horse thing that would make anyone
scared of horses frankly it's pretty
dope though despite Envy showing up to
take gluttony home they both get wrapped
up into a fight with Ed Al and Lynn
obviously link takes Envy while Ed and
Al tried to tango with gluttony I love
all of these fights in this section of
the story because they're all never
really just as simple as the guy destroy
blah blah blah this entire scene is made
possible because envy and gluttony are
under strict orders not to do any damage
to Edward or Al which creates really
interesting encounters I think like when
Ed and Al were trying to bait them into
the situation or like right now where
something really cool happens and before
I get to that I think something that's
become apparent is that Ling is a
fantastic character to watch fight and
make sense of a given situation with in
a world filled with what are effectively
magic wielders he's just a dude with a
sword he just happens to be cunning with
some pockets and deceptively capable
[Music]
dang this is a really cool Moment by the
way but when Ed steps in front of Ling
as he's about to be eaten by gluttony I
gotta say damn first the arakawa knows
exactly how to write characters that let
their actions do the talking and
secondly holy crap I picked such a crazy
spot to stop it last week like ever
since then the fighting has been
happening again and again and again and
it's been amazing like let me paint you
a picture so I'm enjoying myself you
know reading the manga having fun and
then gluttony eats both Ed and Lynn
whole like what the hell is happening
I'm sad Al is sad the whole thing is sad
okay it's not that sad
oh God
the journey inside of the belly of
gluttony is largely funny if not
slightly unsettling given there's no
clear way out but I think this is also a
wonderful look at what makes Full Metal
Alchemist as great as it is in microcosm
last week I touted a fantastic trait
Edward has in the ability to keep
pressing forward despite how impossible
things at present seem Lin even brings
this up in this very section they've
shot guns in this space open bottomless
Holes in the Floor and have found that
there doesn't seem to be any logical end
to this place they've been trapped
within it's very much just like their
overall goal in the story seems
impossible but that doesn't stop Edward
from earnestly trying cracking wise and
remaining steadfast in his goal to move
forward he refuses to accept defeat
stubborn to the end it's a wonderfully
consistent character trait I think
foreign
Civil War and thus the one behind scars
killing intent motivation and by proxy
the one that was indirectly responsible
for winry's parent death
foreign
[Music]
ready to fight is grotesque and almost
like something out of a berserk comic
easily the most impressive visual in the
story so far I think outside of that
impending fight arakawa is setting up
the pieces of this proverbial chessboard
for later the alphon storyline is taken
to an admittedly very interesting
Direction when he demonstrates further
growth by thinking on his feet by being
decisive and actually convincing the
impressionable gluttony to bring him to
his father the super villain behind all
of this the big bad that's AKA is dead
this should be interesting and secondly
we haven't seen him in a short while but
Mustang is currently walking into the
lion's den so to speak without knowing
any better it's extremely tense as he
returns to the government HQ to see if
he can find out or confirm that wrath is
in fact wrath tense because we know he's
going in to inspect the authenticity of
this certain rumor but additionally
tense because we know that Bradley
suspects him already from earlier in the
story and a general eggs Mustang into a
meeting room with all the higher ups to
tell this joke that he was using the
test of order and he has to do it to
Bradley's face I mean it's a terrific
scene but I was on the edge of my seat
all throughout this thing but the long
story short is he and Hawkeye are now
essentially hostages of some sort Envy
versus Lin and Edward so what do you do
when you're stuck in an infinite void
and need to kill the time try to kill
each other the fight here confronts
Edward with a lot of difficult decisions
though puts him into a lot of
compromising situations that Ling has to
bail him out of until he can't any long
but lying dazed on the floor Ed
recognizes a piece of rock next to it
something we've all seen But honestly I
didn't even really twig it the piece
that was missing from the ruin he saw
back in the desert that's a really cool
catch and furthermore the Revelation
that Envy is composed of all the
civilians that lived in that ghost town
Xerxes and capital A N D and was the one
who started the Civil War by killing
that little kid actually rocked my
ever-loving world when I read it like I
have no idea why I never suspected that
before shape-shifting and pretending to
be different people and creatures has
literally been Envy's entire ammo and
gimmick up until now I feel like the
biggest idiot for not guessing that
earlier but arikawa nice going and this
isn't even the wildest part Edward opens
up the same sort of Port he did before
and in the process
sees Al's Body and that might be the
wildest scene I think the story has ever
delivered for me I got literal chills
reading that and I'm serious it doesn't
end there because my theory was ruined
again in the same video I know whatever
okay it's a trend right now full amount
of Alchemist you beat me okay whatever
remember I said that hohenheim was the
big bad behind all this
well it turns out he's not apparently
it's the evil twin brother with no
memory of who their father is
um he just so happens to look like
hohenheim and just so happens to have
comparable Powers I guess okay I have
honestly no idea what's going on anymore
Ed Lin and envy come exploding out of
gluttony because that's cool not
hohenheim somehow heals Edward with some
sort of divine magic and manifests
another hand out of literally nowhere
for Al like where does he get the
material why can he do all of this
without so much as moving a muscle and
the way with which this dude talks like
he talks as if he was a God talking to
Insects meanwhile we get a short cutaway
to hornheim for arakawa to rub it into
my wound right now because he's hiking
up the mountains for some specific
reason that I have no idea about I mean
is he responsible for creating this
person I mean baby is he a person I'm
not even sure I'm over 50 chapters deep
and I am literally more confused now
than when I first started like hoan time
in the mountains not the one in the
creepy underground bunker but one of the
mountains who knows that something
massively dangerous is happening I mean
he warned pinako about this I mean like
that's that massive event where their
town is trapped in some transmutation
circle I mean so surely he must be in on
it right like guys I'm genuinely at a
complete loss here this might be the
very first time a story has completely
stumped me my theory is out the window
and I feel nothing but failure and
sadness naturally because all of that
shock and you know him threatening Lin's
life because he's quote unimportant Ed
jumps into action against Envy I love
the contrast By the way we see here
between Ed with conviction in this sane
versus Envy and Ed without conviction
versus Envy you know in the depths of
gluttony he lost the will to fight and
it was reflected in how he fared against
the homunculi but here he seems to be
less concerned with envy and more so
this dude who totally isn't his dad and
he fares much better that is until he
turns off his transmutation power
seriously the more I read the more
confused I'm becoming and now he's
turning link into new greed
the single most insane chapter my little
heart can take it the only thing that
would make this more insane would be if
Skyward
look at this
oh hey look it's the little girl with
the panda bear that I've neglected to
mention properly up until now
check this out right so scar comes to
the rescue so he's sort of like the
anti-hero meets the heroes to fight
against some common enemy type of guy
and he even has one of those moments
where the anti-hero is all like maybe we
aren't so different after all in his
head he says that in his head and then
throws Al's head at a pipe to make the
chimeras explode okay I explained that
poorly but I don't care I want to go
back to Reading More
[Music]
wait is that it did Mark just leave the
video without a conclusion is the
conclusion what do we do what do we do
then
[Music]
foreign